et maintenant
ouais si et rigueur
elle est en bon soir bonsoir lens est
grand reporter spécialiste de politique
étrangère auteurs de la guerre du golfe
le dossier secret en collaboration avec
pierre salinger auteur de tempête du
désert et de la guerre des bouches dont
vous nous avez parlé sur ce plateau
c'est là que j'avais annoncé que le
grand père bush avait fait du business
avec les nazis
et puis aussi que les bush était en
affaire avec des proches de ben laden
le livre s'est bien vendu j'imagine
parce qu'il y avait quand même du
biscuit devant wind on s'est très bien
vendu et il s'est rendu également dans
19 pays
ah ouais mais sauf aux états unis s'est
rendu en chine en russie a été baissée
l'air par des scellés en allemagne mais
moi non plus propre aux états unis votre
nouveau livre s'appelle le monde secret
de bouche
alors la question que vous posez lancé
avec laurent intéresse tout le monde la
question c'est qui gouverne réellement
l'amérique voilà un
alors ça commence avec l'élection de
dubaï où une élection contestable avec
337 milles 576 vote deux mois que le
perdant
le point de départ de cette enquête que
j'ai menée aux états unis s'étaient en
effet ça cette élection qui était
étrange controversé et dans laquelle
j'ai découvert que notamment deux juges
de la cour suprême qui ont fait basculer
le vote en faveur donc vu de george
deubeuliou bush étaient des proches à la
fois de la famille bush et l'autre aussi
été mêlé à des milieux d'extrême droite
aux élections contestables et contestées
est ce que vous racontez dans votre
livre de plus grave c'est que le jeune
bouche double you a vaincu son complexe
par rapport à son père et sa dépendance
à l'alcool
grâce à la bible et depuis c'est un
illuminé quoi jésus dit il et son
penseur préféré sa mère le prend pour
moïse enfin c'est très inquiétant voler
votre truc
oui non le vrai problème c'est que le
seul livre le premier livre que de
georges de luc boucher lui de la
première à la dernière ligne
c'est d'être c'est à l'âge de 39 ans la
bible ouais mais dans les conditions
assez précis c'est qu'en effet le
traverser une crise une crise
personnelle grave il buvait leçon
monnaie son ménage battait de l aile et
donc il y avait un de ses amis qui
traverse également que de grosses
difficultés un texan comme nuit et qui
est toujours qui est aujourd'hui remise
du commerce
ouais ouais et pendant deux ans ses
hommes se sont-ils deux hommes qui
aujourd'hui ont les postes-clés sont
immergés dans les faits donc la lecture
attentive de la bible et doux bush est
ressorti transfiguré en disant j'ai
trouvé un ami en la personne de jésus et
l'a d'ailleurs dit peu après
juste après son entrée à la maison
blanche il a lié un groupe en effet donc
de responsables religieux il a dit vous
savez je suis persuadé que dieu une
mission pour moi autant je ne serais pas
là je serai dans un bar du texas et non
pas dans le bureau ovale et art ce qui
est plus grave évidemment c'est
l'entourage
alors il ya beaucoup d' illuminé autour
de lui un bon coup qu'ils croient au
retour de l'antéchrist au retour du
messie en forme et dans un délire accès
wi moi ce qui m'a intéressé c'est ce que
j'ai trouvé fascinant non dans cette
enquête c'est qu'au fur et à mesure que
j'avançais ont trouvé en effet les
personnages qui sont des personnages
extrêmement inquiétant qui croit en
effet que nous sommes à la veille de la
fin du monde alors on pourrait penser
que ce sont des marginaux sont entre 15
et 18 millions donc des lecteurs qui
soutiennent george deubeuliou boucher
qui sont des chrétiens fanatiques opposé
mais absolument opposé à tout ce qui est
en effet libéralisation des moeurs
évidemment avortement n'en parlons pas
contrôler l'aide aux pauvres aux
déshérités aux faibles car izonnais nca
rouge pour les faits beaucoup plus
vraiment bon et sur l'autre erreur qui
s'en va très chrétien on pourrait 800
patrons chrétiens et sur l'autre versant
ils ont une fascination également parce
qu'ils pensent que si l'ajustement la
terre du jugement dernier
il ya une fascination pour israël parce
qu'ils pensent que nous sommes à la
veille de la nouvelle armageddon est
l'antéchrist est déjà sur terre ils nous
disent il est déjà sur terre nous sommes
entrés dans la lutte du bien et du mal
et il va y avoir bientôt le retour en
effet donc du messie mais un messi qui
sera chrétiens et semer cyr et
instaurera le royaume de dieu mais alors
évidemment ne survivront nous survivrons
à leur logique que les vrais chrétiens
il est le grand mère dit les juifs ni
les musulmans
et comme le disait d'ailleurs un
observateur julie je me dit vous savez
c'est une pièce qui ne consomment pas
tellement parce que c'est une pièce
corps cinq actes auxquels les juifs
disparaît ce 4e accueille alors
effectivement il ya beaucoup de
chrétiens sionistes comme vous les
appelez donc c'est le 4e quart d'heure
autour d'eux au tour de george bush
je alors est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que l'exécutif américain est
sous influence
c'est un exécutif qui est sous influence
et en même temps c'est un exécutif qui
n'a cynisme incroyable parce que c'est
véritablement le principe fait ce que je
veux ce que je dis mais pas ce que je
suis mais c'est à dire que par exemple
vous avez donc et déclarations qui ont
été faites par le vice président
américain dick cheney et dick cheney
avant de devenir vice-président était le
pdg de la plus grande société de
services pétroliers au monde qui
s'appelle halliburton et halliburton sa
société alors qu'il en était le
président a violé donc et tournai
l'embargo sur l'irak pour vendre du
matériel pétroliers à saddam hussein il
ya aussi l'exemple extraordinaire du
ministre en effet d'adèle du ministre
défense monsieur romstad et monsieur
comme celle dont qui a été au conseil
d'administration d'un énorme groupe qui
s'appelle abb qui est un groupe à la
fois suisse et et suédois en l'an 2000
2000 approuvé la vente par ce groupe
donc à la corée du nord de deux
centrales nucléaires
213 pays décrit comme l'axé du mal alors
est ce que en disant ça en disant que
finalement aux etats unis aujourd'hui il
ya une forte influence de ce que vous
appelez les chrétiens sionistes qui sont
des alliés objectifs en tous les cas du
likoud pour le moment tous les cas en
disant qu autour de george bush ya
beaucoup de juifs qui sont liées au
likoud est ce que vous prenez pas de
risque d'alimenter la théorie du grand
complot juif mondial certainement pas je
m'en voudrais bien donc bien entendu non
non non il n'en est pas question
mais vous dites quand même que dans le
clan des faucons les pro-israéliens le
11 septembre a été une opportunité
saisie une partie des chrétiens venus
pour mettre en pratique leur politique
et que la guerre directe donc un premier
pas en fait par rapport à un remodelage
du mais regardez aujourd'hui la
polémique qui se développe sur les armes
de destruction massive
dray sur le fait qu'on ne trouve pas sur
les faits qu'on est en effet donc si un
membre d'un démenti et certains défauts
qu'on le reconnaisse ouvertement avec
une espèce de cynisme tranquille on en
est si on a choisi la solution qui
pouvait rallier la plus large opinion
c'est comme tout à fait étonnant on a
menti au peuple et la guerre on annonce
l idée
voilà de faux rapports exactement
aujourd'hui on a menti au peuple
américain ont nommé menti à l'opinion
internationale
mais aujourd'hui c'est comme
l'extraordinaire la mise en condition à
travers la presse justement dont qui à
travers un certain nombre de télévision
notamment la chaîne du magna multi
milliardaire rupert murdoch qui est très
proche des bouches est telle que les
américains 43 % des américains sont
persuadés qu'on a quand même trouvé les
armes de destruction massive à
l'intérieur du territoire irakien
restent extraordinaire mais d'ailleurs
paul wolkowitsky est un qui est un
faucon incarner au conservateur a
déclaré récemment dans vanity fair que
les armes de destruction massive était
en fait une raisons bureaucratiques le
samedi une invention complète même lui
le dit dans un journal qui est certes
réservé à l'élite américaine des crânes
publiés aux états unis bien sûr un oui
mais bien sur la liste mais quel cynisme
oui mais vous savez c'est un deuxième
but de votre gueule on vous le disent
pas grave
voilà il faut ajouter une composante
aussi quelle extraordinaire et que j'ai
découvert semoun fameux secte moon est
le fondateur de la secte moon son est
très proche très proche vraiment de bush
il a soutenu donc d'orge de menus bush
il a soutenu le bush père lorsqu'il
s'est présenté à la présidence et bush
père accepte de faire des conférences
pour donc moon à travers le monde et
pour les organisations de moon à travers
le monde est payé sayyert bien qu'il
soit millionnaire payer 100 mille
dollars l'heure et il ya une espèce
d'alliance extraordinairement contre
nature entre cette extrême droite
fanatiques et moon qui est une secte
dangereuse qu'elle est interdite dans
nombreux pays la foule présente
non mais ça fait flipper franchement
guignen et après tu ne sors plus de chez
toi le grand frère bullshit et du
business avec les nazis
eh oui
il ne se tienne mais oui oui à d azur
c'est ça qui fondent le bourdon en
déformant et non c'est ça qui est
effrayant et il ya un certain nombre de
relais dans la presse et dans dans la
télévision et dans les journaux qui ont
servi effectivement donc efficacement
donc à avaler à la française et ses
idées parce que quand je dis à la
bataille des idées
il y a ce que je raconte il ya un
certain nombre de fondations d'extrême
droite notamment est un personnage
fascinant et un personnage qui s'appelle
ska mellon mais l'homme qui a été le
premier d'ailleurs la finance et les
mellon c'est la famille la plus riche
des états unis et avec les avec les
rockefeller et les mellon donc sont des
banquiers procède en effet donc le des
dents intérêts dans le pétrole
skf mellon est une espèce de personnages
qu'ils n'eussent paix de milliardaires
qui vit reclus totalement reclus et à
pittsburgh et il a utilisé son immense
fortune plus d'un milliard de dollars
pour financer des institutions qui sont
aujourd'hui des institutions qui ont
l'esprit sont installés donc depuis 20
ans et qui ont totalement remodelé le
paysage social c'est-à-dire qu'il a en
effet mais je veux dire par exemple au
niveau des moeurs visons ans est une
véritable bataille contre les pauvres à
une véritable bataille d'un homme non en
faveur du racisme et daro ségrégation il
ya par exemple les penseurs américains
donc aujourd'hui les plus les plus
connus qui explique qu'il faut abolir
l'acte sur l'égalité raciale de 1964
donc c'est bien il le dit clairement et
qu'on a le droit en effet deux on
devrait avoir le droit de discriminer
aussi bien donc en matière d'emploi
qu'en matière de logement c'est une
guerre qui a été lancée je veux dire de
quand je disais que c'est un gars qui a
été lancée contre les faits contre les
pots par tous ces gens et c'est donc
vous m'expliquer par exemple il ya un
homme qui a financé un livre et une à
une organisation qui ont financé 1 lille
qui s'appelle loathing grande bon peu
importe et qui a été une bible pour tous
les amateurs de lecture on explique que
la pauvreté c'est pas dus aux crises
économiques c'est dieu nature des gens
c'est dur et fait sens ils sont cons oui
il fallait en gros c'est ça et le type a
récidivé après les livres là on a voulu
et trop aider les pauvres et on roule
entre eux et les pauvres la fabriquer
beaucoup encore beaucoup trop de pauvres
est là
sidibé après avec un autre livre
s'appelle de bell curve qui a été lancé
par cette organisation ultra
conservatrice qui a été à des livres de
chevet aussi le jazz de benue bouge dans
lequel il explique la cette fois ci que
en fait les l'inégalité donc
d'intelligence ou fin aux différences de
cuir résulte en effet dont condé rasera
d'eric laurent c'est quand même excusez
moi une vision éclairée yens du monde
non c'est une règle d hubert mansion et
des surhommes oui oui non c'est de la
vision d'hitler c'est tout à fait
étonnant c'est une vision absolument
totalement nous nous verrons america
mais absolument voix l'amérique mais
baron m'expliquer quand ils sont arrivés
en 44 qui nous ont libérés et
aujourd'hui être obligé de se coller
dans le cigare qui sont devenus
carrément d'après ce que vous dites
enfin pas tous faire mais pas tous en
tous les cas ces mecs-là des quasi
hitlérien c'est terrible à imaginer
alors est ce qu'on peut dire avec
laurent comme norman mailer dansant dans
son dernier livre que l'amérique
finalement est passée la démocratie l
empire oui bien sûr et cette vision
impérialistes s'accompagne d'une vision
arrogante par exemple envers la france
ouais je veux dire la manière dont en
effet nous nous sommes mis en travers du
chemin jeux 2d décision américaine a été
quelque chose qui était totalement
brocardé et d'ailleurs on est allé
jusqu'au point de par exemple d'utiliser
et de réécrire les marseillais voulez
que je vous dise oui à c'est tout à fait
étonnant c'est tout à fait étonnant non
non j'ai tout d'abord été par ailleurs
dit non parce que c'est tout à fait
étonnant quand même et c'est décrit par
hun l'organe des néoconservateurs
américains c'est à dire que c'est pas du
tout un organe vraiment bas de gamme et
ses terrasses et écrit par un monsieur
qui s'appelle christol et la nouvelle
marseillaise donc à 1 et paroles
suivantes
allons enfants de la patrie rendons-nous
encore détester nous approchons chaque
tyrannie avec la même servilité nous
brillons à la servilité l'amerloque
demande l'assistance mais nous rions
dans son visage bien sûr c'est notre
héritage
deux points plus tard nous joindrons la
résistance et george bush est un sauvage
mais la france a plus de fromage
marchons marchons faisons parade de nos
prétentions
qu'est-ce qui a écrit ça un monsieur qui
s'appelle christol et qui allait sur les
sols william kristol et la wii
christol